se nos dice que a veces
efe es un hexágono regular esta parte de
regular bueno obviamente hexágono nos
dice que estamos tratando con 6 lados
puedes contarlos pero la parte de
regular nos deja saber que todos los
lados los 6 tienen la misma longitud y
todos los ángulos interiores miden lo
mismo después nos dan información de que
la longitud de uno de los lados bueno
pero es un hexágono regular así que en
si está diciendo que todos los lados
miden dos raíz de tres así que cada uno
de estos lados mide dos raíz de tres y
bueno quieren que encontremos el área
del hexágono encuentra el área de abs de
efe y ahora la mejor manera de encontrar
el área especialmente para polígonos
regulares es intentar dividirlo en
triángulos así que bueno el hexágono es
un caso especial
quizás en futuros vídeos pensemos en el
caso general para amd para cualquier
polígono en el hexágono si tomamos a
este punto y lo llamamos g y digamos
bueno que este punto es el centro ahora
cuando yo hablo del centro del hexágono
me refiero a un punto que no es x está
a cada uno de los puntos porque porque
no es un círculo pero si es si es
equidistante cada uno de los vértices
entonces jefe es igual a gea es igual a
jefe es igual a g y bueno yo voy a
dibujar aquí líneas que conectan cada
uno de los vértices entonces esto es que
esto es gd esto es jefe esto es jefe y
así para cada uno de los de los
segmentos que unen el centro con cada
vértice ahora bien cada uno de estos
mide lo mismo cada segmento desde el
centro hasta cada vértice miden lo mismo
y también sabemos que si vamos todo
alrededor de un círculo así como
viajando habremos recorrido 360 grados y
sabemos que todos estos triángulos todos
van a ser congruentes unos a otros y la
manera más sencilla de mostrar eso bueno
tenemos 22 lados iguales en un triángulo
pero todos los triángulos miden lo mismo
así que todos estos son congruentes
porque está en el centro y todos tienen
este tercer lado en común 2 raíz de 3
así que por lado lado a lado
todos estos triángulos
iguales y también por ejemplo bueno
estos ángulos interiores todos estos
ángulos interiores también miden lo
mismo los seis ángulos miden lo mismo
son iguales y los voy a llamar
x entonces este es x también este es x
todos son x porque miden lo mismo y si
los sumas habremos dado la vuelta a un
círculo habremos recorrido 360 grados
tenemos seis de ellos así que 6x es
igual a 360 dividimos ambos lados en 36
y tenemos que x es igual a 60 así que
todos estos ángulos son igual a 60 y
aquí hay algo muy interesante porque por
ejemplo el triángulo gbc y podría ser
cualquier triángulo entonces sabemos que
estos triángulos son isósceles esta
distancia de aquí esta distancia es
igual a esta distancia de acá y ahora ya
podemos averiguar cuánto miden los otros
ángulos porque tenemos aquí triángulos
isósceles este es un triángulo isósceles
con estos lados iguales así que los
ángulos de la base este ángulo será
igual a este ángulo le ponemos bien y
entonces tenemos que llenar que es igual
a 2 yemas 60 es igual a 180 esto es
igual a 180 porque la suma de los
ángulos internos de un triángulo
es igual a 180 restamos 60 de ambos
lados y obtenemos que 2 y es igual a 120
y dividimos ambos lados entre 2 entonces
y es igual a 60 ahora esto lo puede
haber hecho con cualquiera de los
triángulos son triángulos de 60 60 60 y
esto nos dice por lo que ya vimos cuando
empezamos a estudiar triángulos
equiláteros aquí te aquí estamos
tratando con triángulos donde los
ángulos miden 60 todos así que lo cual
nos indica que es un triángulo
equilátero entonces este lado mide 2
raíz de 3 y también estrado mide 2 raíz
de 3 y también en este otro de acá todos
cada uno de ellos miden 2 raíz de tres y
ya sabemos eso porque es un hexágono
regular y bueno que cada lado del
hexágono mide también 2 raíz de 3
entonces ahora podemos usar esta
información para averiguar bueno de
hecho no tengo que averiguar nada hay un
momento de mente explicó que me refiero
pero podemos averiguar el área de uno de
estos triángulos y luego multiplicarlo
multiplicar ese número por 6 así que me
voy a enfocar en este triángulo y bueno
y el lado de semi de dos raíz de tres y
podemos dibujar una altitud una altitud
dejar caer aquí una altitud ahora
sabemos que este triángulo equilátero y
podemos mostrar muy fácilmente que estos
dos triángulos son simétricos así que
estos dos ángulos miden 90
estos dos ángulos miden 60 y si miras a
cada uno de estos triángulos la suma de
los ángulos internos debe sumar 180 así
que bueno por ende cada uno de estos
ángulos mide 30 ahora cada uno de estos
ángulos también miden lo mismo y
comparten un mismo lado estos dos
triángulos así que son triángulos
congruentes y si queremos encontrar el
área de esta rebanada de pastel
podríamos simplemente encontrar el área
de una de estas su prueba nada y bueno
multiplicarlo por dos o en contra el
área y multiplicarlo por 12 para el
hexágono completo entonces bueno como
encontramos el área para esta cosa
veamos la mitad de la longitud de la
base mide raíz de 3 cierto y bueno
llamemos a este punto h
así que vih mide raíz de 3
ya debemos reconocer que esto es un
triángulo 30 60 90
lo voy a dibujar por acá y bueno esto es
un triángulo 30 60 90 y sabemos que esta
longitud mide raíz de 3 y también ya
sabemos que la hipotenusa mide 2 raíz de
3 así que queremos averiguar cuánto mide
este lado esta altitud esto cuánto mide
ahora bueno por lo visto unos triángulos
de 30 60 90
aunque el lado opuesto a los 60 grados
es de raíz de 3 x el lado opuesto al
ángulo de 30 grados así que tenemos raíz
de 3 x raíz de 3 cierto raíz de 3 x raíz
de 3 y bueno eso simplemente es 3 así
que esta altitud es igual a 3 y entonces
si queremos el área de este triángulo el
cual es este triángulo de aquí es un
medio por base por altura el área de
este de esta sub rebanada es de un medio
por base por altura entonces un medio x
esta base bueno de hecho de hechos y de
hecho mejor tomemos estaban directamente
el área de todo este triángulo el
triángulo
y entonces me regreso en esto un poco
aquí de borrón ahora porque ahora
tenemos la base y la altura de este
triángulo de todo el triángulo y si
queremos encontrar el área del triángulo
gdc ahora quiero encontrar el área de
todo este triángulo entonces esto es
igual a un medio por base por altura por
base por altura y un medio lo cual es
cuál es nuestra base cuánto mide ya
sabemos que mide 2 raíz de 3 entonces un
medio por 2 raíz de 3 y queremos
multiplicar eso por la altura así que
eso ya lo sabemos ya lo pudimos
averiguar usando lo que sabemos de
triángulos de 30 60 90 nuestra altura es
de 3 un medio y 12 cancela y nos queda 3
raíz de 3 es el área para solamente un
triángulo si queremos encontrar el área
para todo el hexágono simplemente
multiplicamos por 6 porque tenemos 6
triángulos y entonces tenemos que 6 por
3 raíz de tres así que 6 por 3 raíz de 3
eso es igual a 18 raíz de 3
ese es el área